un poète mais surtout un interprète qui
donne toute la dimension aux textes qui
racontent la réunion ii grand-mère azzam
al en passant par claire mahler toutes
les chansons douces à nou sava sont
inscrites dans la mémoire collective
cela fait 30 ans que frédéric joron le
leader historique du groupe ousanousava
sème à tout vent l'âme de la réunion
alors ce samedi sera l'occasion de
chanter et de rechanter encore les plus
beaux titres du répertoire de la famille
joron
un petit peu tout des artistes d'avant
et maintenant et puis on a la
possibilité de pouvoir joindre l'utile à
l'agréable de jouer avec des gens comme
on l'a jamais joué et puis des gens que
on a pu côtoyer lors d'une petite
prestation principale c'est vraiment un
gros câlin mélange ne peut pas la donne
à nous le virus quand même
du séga du mandat et puis là envie de
monter en scène jouée faire de la
musique tout ça sur scène d'autres
artistes viendront prêter leur voix à
ces titres qui pour certains ont été
écrits alors qu'eux mêmes n'étaient pas
nés davy sicard stéphanie thazar ou
encore yale trulès seront de la fête
et puis on retrouvera aussi les anciens
parmi eux l'un des musiciens du groupe
mascarenhas patrick manoro qui est
également guide péi à salazie dans
l'inconnu frédéric comme un spectacle
mascarenhas et c'est vrai que dans ma
tête me donner me mettais frédéric aux
intouchables et comment laconi frédéric
le jour du spectacle comme a connu à
lima la rencontre que c'est quelqu'un
très humaniste donc des gens ils
soulignent pas mais ces quelques très
proche de lot est mon métier un musicien
comme l'y de son gabarit un musicien
très connu qui reste dans cette île
magnifique
côté changes avec l'autre pour moi c'est
ça le musicien frédéric a confié les
rênes de la soirée à willy fontaine et
gérard itema l'esprit c'est vraiment que
les avait invités
la nive et c'est enrique salem les
invités que nous voir ils ont évité de
mon avis de bon si les gens achètent de
passe mais c'est comme si c'est bien
fait anniversaire eric dans la course
des rixes shopping pas rester dans
l'effet de surprise
dites vous qu'il y aura plusieurs
invités
l'ambiance bien sûr festif inquiétez pas
pour ça et venez venez vous allez
découvrir quelque chose d'assez
impressionnant par une belle soirée donc
en perspective du côté du théâtre en
plein air de saint gilles avec l'ail
jour on est tous ses invités une soirée
pour se souvenir pour chanter danser et
surtout faire la fête
bien plus
à chanter